we are just a few days away from the
first raiders home game of the regular
season and if you're going you have to
be at least partially vaccinated but a
new vaccine screening option could make
the whole process a whole lot smoother
sasha loftus joins us live from the
legion stadium with more tonight sasha
brian these requirements are still a
point of contention but this new option
could make things go a little smoother
for anyone heading through the doors
here at allegiant stadium on monday some
believe it could also encourage raider
fans to get their shots
the countdown is on to the raiders first
regular season home game
but feelings are still mixed on covid
vaccine requirements at allegiant
stadium i think that what they're doing
is a good thing the situation we're in
really hurts the team announced its
efforts wednesday to make things smooth
for anyone attending the most important
thing is for people to act early and to
be prepared in most cases vaccine
information can be scanned onto an app
for immediate access but if you're
partially vaccinated or have a shot from
another country
alternate screening is open ahead of the
game to save time and stress do it that
one time well in advance to game day so
that you can fly through the gates
easily there's also an option to get
immunized at the door which could work
toward increasing our numbers statewide
i'm sure you'll have about 20 percent of
those say hey you know what i don't pay
all this money i already came here i
can't get my tickets back i'm going to
get vaccinated anyway and while some say
these benefits still aren't enough to
sway them people have already purchased
their tickets they can't get refunded
others tell us they're ready to root for
the silver and black safely we could
still
show our support for the team and you
know be feel safe to feel safe at the
same time
anyone who's still partially vaccinated
on monday or anyone who gets their
vaccine in this tent here in lot b of
allegiance stadium on game day still has
to wear a mask for those raiders games
now as as for those advanced screening
options we have an entire look at those
options at when those dates and times
are on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now